[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEREMY: Thank you again
for coming on out.
My name's Jeremy, and I lead
up the Asian Google Network
here in our Los Angeles office.
We do events revolving around
professional development,
community service.
And this week, we're
focusing on race affairs.
So this talk today is part of
a series of different events
that we're hosting,
so if you want
to find out more about what it
means to be AAPI, please visit
our [? GoLink, ?] go/aapi.
So without further ado, I'm
going to go ahead and start off
our panel today.
We have with us today "Asian
AF," or "Asian as Beep."
[LAUGHTER]
KEIKO AGENA: Can we not swear?
JEREMY: Um.
AUDIENCE: Yes, you can.
Yes, it's fine.
[LAUGHTER]
KIM COOPER: He said it's fine.
KEIKO AGENA: I don't know
who that gentleman is.
KIM COOPER: That's Google.
That's Google right there.
AUDIENCE: You guys totally
can, but Jeremy's at work.
[? PANEL: ?] Oh.
JEREMY: Feel free.
You are my guests.
So-- I don't need a censor.
So I'm going to
read a brief intro.
So "Asian AF" is the hit
Asian American variety show
based in Los
Angeles and features
exclusively Asian
American performers.
The group made headlines earlier
this year for their efforts
to fight against damaging
Asian stereotypes through humor
and their viral T-shirt poking
fun of Hollywood whitewashing,
pictured right there.
Join us right now
for this panel,
and we'll talk about
Asian representation
in media and entertainment.
So what we'll do right now is
I'd love to get some intros.
Please introduce
yourself, your name,
give us a little
bit of background,
and what brought you to comedy.
ZAC OYAMA: Hi, I'm Zac Oyama.
I work at College Humor
as a writer and actor
there, and make videos for them.
What brought me to comedy?
I guess I don't know.
I just have always enjoyed
it and use it as a way
to just, from a
young age, trying
to win over friends by trying
to be funny or whatever.
And yeah, that's where
it probably started.
Yeah.
WILL CHOI: Hi, I'm Will Choi.
I'm the creator of "Asian AF"
and also another show comedy
show at the UCB Theater called
"Scarlett Johansson Presents."
And I got into comedy
a few years ago
after watching an improv show.
And yeah, that's basically it.
I just saw improv, and
I fell in love with it,
and then that's what
brought me here.
KEIKO AGENA: Hi, everybody.
My name's Keiko Agena,
and I'm an actress.
I'm a cohost of "Asian AF."
And I've been acting
for a long time.
And some of the roles
are comedic or dramedy,
and things like that.
I was on a show called "Gilmore
Girls" for seven years,
and then I did their
reboot of that.
And I guess, if we're talking
about strictly comedy,
I came into it because
I love to laugh,
and I'm obsessed with it.
And improv is some of
the best entertainment
I've ever experienced.
It's the thing that makes
me laugh the hardest.
So it's the thing that
I'm the most obsessed
with in trying to
perfect because I
feel like it's this puzzle
that never can be solved.
And so it's tickling
to my brain,
and so that's why I can
never get enough of it,
and I love the show.
KIM COOPER: Hi, I'm Kim Cooper,
and I'm an actress as well.
And I came to comedy
because I grew up in Iowa.
I'm adopted.
And so I grew up
in a place where
I didn't feel like I fit in.
And I felt like I often times--
as a lot of people do who come
to comedy--
I came to comedy because
I was like, oh, I
need a way to figure out how
to cope with feeling different
and, in a way, make fun of
myself before other people can.
And so that's how I
ended up doing that.
And then improv,
specifically, I came to
because it's something
where people can't tell you
that who you are,
what you look like,
means you have to be
something specific.
In improv, it's all
made up on the fly.
So it's like, hey, right now,
I'm going to be the president,
and that's just how it is.
The president's an Asian woman.
That's what it is.
And so that's why
I really like that.
KAY KAANAPU: Hello, my
name is Kay Kaanapu.
I'm originally from
Northern California,
small town named Gilroy,
known for garlic,
so that's where I came from.
I first got into comedy
when I saw an improv show
at my freshman dorm orientation.
It was short form,
and I just thought
it was the coolest thing.
And I was like Liz Lemon.
I was like, I want
to go to there.
And then after that, I started
writing, and just continuing
doing improv, and
pursuing comedy writing.
I currently work for
a TV writer/novelist.
JEREMY: All right,
thanks everyone.
[MIC FEEDBACK]
KIM COOPER: Oh, it
doesn't like it.
JEREMY: Oh.
All right, so my next
question is directed at Will.
We want to know,
how did you come up
with the concept for
the show, "Asian AF"?
WILL CHOI: Yeah.
So it's a little bit of a
story because the first show
before "Asian AF" was
"Scarlett Johansson Presents--
AAPI Heritage Month."
And it was the first
Asian American improv
show at the UCB Theater in LA.
And that happened in response
to "Ghost in the Shell"
and a lot of these
other movies that
have to do with whitewashing
and all that good stuff.
And so the show was
very successful.
It was the very first
Asian American-themed show
at the theater.
And because of the
huge success of that,
UCB gave me "Asian AF,"
which is a variety show.
So it features sketch,
stand up, improv, music,
and different things.
And that show,
"Asian AF," is more
of a celebration of
Asian American performers
doing comedy, where it's not
so much about the whitewashing
controversy and stuff like that.
So it started in
November of 2016.
And because of how successful
the show has been going--
we sell out shows
in, literally, a day.
So because of how
successful it is,
we were able to move it
over to New York as well.
And so in June of 2017 was the
first New York "Asian AF Show."
Yeah.
JEREMY: I'm just turning the
mic on and off just because--
I think it's me.
WILL CHOI: Oh.
Oh, OK.
Glad we figured that out.
JEREMY: Yeah.
So I know you mentioned
"Ghost in the Shell."
And earlier, we were talking
about some news about "Hellboy"
and the reason why--
KEIKO AGENA: Ugh.
JEREMY: Oh, I know, I know.
KEIKO AGENA: Why?
JEREMY: [INAUDIBLE], right?
So for those of you
that don't know,
they made some casting
decisions for the reboot
of the movie, "Hellboy,"
which is based on a comic book
character.
And there is another case of
some Hollywood whitewashing.
So I want to bring
your attention
to Keiko's shirt over here.
So "Scarlett, and Emma,
and Tilda, and Matt."
And this shirt made a lot
of headlines last year.
So we wanted to know, what
was the response like to that?
Did you get a lot of praise?
Did you get any backlash?
Please tell us a little
bit about that story.
WILL CHOI: Yeah.
So this shirt was made--
we made, like, 50 shirts.
We were trying to raise
some money for the show.
And it just so happened
that Michele Selene Ang,
who is on "13 Reasons Why,"
she happened to see this shirt
and wore it.
And that's how it
exploded on the internet.
And the response has been,
or had been, pretty positive.
I think it just resonated
with a lot of people.
I think a lot of people
were feeling frustrated
with a lot of that stuff.
So yeah, generally, people liked
it a lot, and people wear it.
I see people wear it all the
time, and it's really cool.
Yeah.
ZAC OYAMA: What were
we talking about?
[LAUGHTER]
JEREMY: So now that
we're all warmed up--
KIM COOPER: We stay warmed up.
JEREMY: I'm going to
jump to our next question
and talk about some of
the challenges of being
Asian in comedy,
in entertainment.
Could you share some of those
stories, maybe some challenges
you've experienced, and
how you've overcome them?
ZAC OYAMA: For me, I think
I've noticed it's just-- well,
everyone probably has
an experience with this.
But a lot of Asian roles when
I was growing up, less so now,
but the punch line is
that the person's Asian.
And there's very few
instances of characters
that they're just a funny
person, or the role is funny,
and they just
happen to be Asian.
So that's the first
thing that comes to mind.
KAY KAANAPU: I think,
also, it's having
to be the one
person to represent
your ethnicity in the group.
A lot of times, when
you're in a class, or maybe
put on an improv team
for a theater company,
you're usually the one
Asian, or sometimes,
the only one person of color.
So whenever it comes to
references or fun things
that you might
want to talk about,
you're not really pulling from
your personal experiences,
but you're definitely
having to default and adapt
to the group's
personal experiences.
So a lot of times, when I
perform with these people
or with "Asian AF"
performers, you
have this relief that goes over
you because you're just like, I
can talk about [INAUDIBLE].
I can talk about these personal
things that I know in my life
and not feel like I'm
having to train someone
to be like, it's OK,
this is my experience,
or move my comedy towards
their point of view
because that's their reference,
and that's their perspective.
WILL CHOI: In terms
of comedy, yeah--
I don't know.
I'm trying to think about a
specific instance which is not
coming to my head at the moment,
but in terms of just seeing
some stuff on the page of--
OK, so I just thought
of something right now.
There was a short sketch that
someone asked me to be in,
and she was like, hey, we
want you to do this character.
It's a comedic sketch.
The only thing is
we'd like you to do
a stereotypical Asian accent.
And the fact that she said
"stereotypical Asian accent"
was one thing, but I was
just like, I'm sorry.
I can't do that.
And she was like, oh, OK,
let me talk to my director,
and I'll call you back.
And so she calls me
back 10 minutes later,
and she's like, hey,
talked to my director,
we talked about
it, and we're not
going to do an Asian
accent, realized
that it didn't take away
from any of the comedy,
so you could just do it.
And I was like, cool, I
hope you learned something.
You know what I mean?
So there is the layer of the
comedy itself and the words,
and then they wanted to just
put up the accent aspect of it
to heighten it, I guess.
But it doesn't do
anything for it.
It actually makes it
worse, in a sense.
So I was pretty proud of
myself to stand up to that,
even though it was just
a quick, short sketch.
But that is
essentially what a lot
of people who are
in the industry
are dealing with when it comes
to accents and stuff like that.
KIM COOPER: Yeah.
It feels like a lot of the
things that I get sent out for
are specifically
something, dash, ethnic.
It's like, "friend, dash,
ethnic," not just "friend."
And yeah, that is a hard, weird
thing, because you're like,
well, I'm more than ethnic.
I can just be a friend too.
And I think that, especially
in Hollywood, something that's
interesting that I've noticed
too is a lot of things
that I get sent out
for, they specifically
are looking for an Asian
person or an ethnic person.
But then the lead of that
show is still a white person.
And so that propagates
this idea that people
of color or Asian people
only populate a world that
centers around white people.
And so sometimes, that just
feels like a hard thing
to be having to consider
when you go on an audition,
or you get sent on an
audition, and if you get it,
and you're like, oh,
thank god, they're
not asking my to do an
accent, which I'm also
very uncomfortable doing.
I'm from Iowa.
My parents are white.
[LAUGHTER]
I have a very Midwestern
life experience.
But then on top of that,
it's like, aw, man, yeah,
that's a bummer.
Just a reminder, again,
that this is not my world.
I just am also
here, dash, ethnic.
KEIKO AGENA: Also, if you
asked us to go down the line
and do our Asian accents,
we all suck at them.
I guarantee it.
WILL CHOI: Guaranteed.
KEIKO AGENA: I think I only
can do stereotypical Asian, not
country-specific.
I'm like, [? that-- ?] what
are you going for, Keiko?
It's not good.
What are we doing?
I'm sick, so I'm going to be
asking that every five minutes.
WILL CHOI: Keiko is sick, so
we're happy that she's here.
KEIKO AGENA: Too much honesty.
JEREMY: Well, thanks
for still joining us.
And honesty always
is appreciated.
All right.
I think that's good.
So speaking of
these stereotypes,
how do you feel that your
comedy helps to address it
or to help combat that issue?
WILL CHOI: I mean, we have a
lot of very talented writers
and performers at our show.
Kay is one of the writers.
KEIKO AGENA: I
love Kay's writing.
WILL CHOI: And a lot of our
sketches that we do actually
have to do with race,
but some of them do.
And the ones that deal with
race in a very smart way
are the ones that I
gravitate towards.
And they'll address it, and I
can't even really explain it.
But they'll find ways
to kind of flip things
on its head a little bit.
And, yeah, I don't
know, that's the stuff
that I really like a lot.
You know, it's not just
people doing bad accents
and being weird or
anything like that.
It's smart.
It's really smart comedy.
And Zac's a writer too.
ZAC OYAMA: Yeah.
Oh, hey.
You know, most of
us up here do improv
and almost never it comes up
in shows I do that I'm Asian.
I just like to do
what I think is funny
and usually almost never
have to comment on it.
And, you know,
comedically, I think
just being a funny person
is what I gravitate to,
trying to do.
And then, yeah,
like talking about,
like, I usually won't
write a sketch that
has to do with being
Asian, unless there's
like an actual point to it.
Like you were saying
when me and a coworker
wrote a sketch that was like--
I forget like the
exact title, but it's
like am I Asian enough?
And there's like this panel
talking to a guy who's
like an eighth Asian.
And he's like trying
to figure out,
can I say the three Korean
phrases I know or does
that seem racist?
Can I-- you know, like asking
sort of stereotypical questions
about being Asian
just because like,
you know, there is sort of a
weirdness to being half or part
Asian, like what is OK?
Is that question weird?
What is OK?
Because it is like
who you are too.
KAY KAANAPU: Yeah, and I think
when it comes to writing, just
the fact that you
can write a character
and then not refer
to their culture
or make the story
about their culture
or their ethnic
experience and they still
can be an ethnic person.
Like, I have written
a bunch of TV pilots.
And whenever I table
read them, I always
have like 100% diverse cast.
And the only time that I
will change a description
to put that they're actually
ethnic in the description
is when I send it out
to readers so they
know I expect a person of
color to be in that part.
But the actual
story and dialogue
has nothing to do
with their ethnicity.
So for me the whole idea
is like you can just
write about people, and
you can just cast people.
You don't have to default
into, like, OK, it
didn't say an ethnicity here
so they must be Caucasian.
KEIKO AGENA: Default
Caucasian [INAUDIBLE]..
KIM COOPER: Yeah, my friend
and I wrote a web series.
And she's black and I'm Asian.
And our aim was not, like,
to make it about that.
We were like, we are women
of color living in this world
that we live in.
So, of course, some
of our experiences
do have to do with that.
Some of the experiences
in all of our lives
do have to do with
our experiences
as Asian-American
people, but that's
not the totality
of our experiences.
And that's not the
totality of we are.
And I think it's
really important--
and that's what is also great
about like, for example, shows
like "Fresh Off The Boat."
Like, not everything
in that show
is about them being
Chinese immigrants.
Like, there are
things in that show
that's just like, the mom
doesn't want one of the kids
to eat a bunch of sugar.
Like, all y'all know about that.
Like, that happens to all of us.
Like, that's not an
exclusively Asian-American
or Asian or immigrant
or Taiwanese experience.
Like that's something
that's still relatable.
And I think that
for me when I write
is really like what I think
is great is like, you know,
it is important
to me to represent
for Asian-American people
and to share the experiences
that we have.
But it's also important to be
like, hey, remember that thing?
Sometimes you put on your
pants, and they don't quite
fit right, right?
Sometimes you can't
find an outfit to wear.
Sometimes you get
a bad haircut too.
Those are the things
that make us all people.
WILL CHOI: At our recent show,
Eugene Cordero was originally
supposed to be here, he showed
a short film that he wrote.
And the short was about--
he's Filipino, and it was
about, like, this Filipino like
folklore thing about like
this monster that eats babies,
right?
And so like even
that kind of stuff,
and to be able to show
that at "Asian AF,"
it's like informative,
but funny.
You know, and it's like
I learned something
about Filipino
culture that night.
You know?
It's just like a really
cool, like I said,
it's a celebration of
Asian cultures and stuff.
So that's-- I think that's
how we combat a stereotypical
Asian, like the stereotypes when
it comes to Asians and comedy.
It's like the way
that we're doing
it is just like showing
the audience like,
this is what is funny.
It has nothing to do with
like stereotypical stuff.
But it still has to do
with Asian culture, which
is really cool.
KEIKO AGENA: [INAUDIBLE]
Oh yeah, one more thing
is that as far as like combating
these issues through comedy,
I don't know what everybody's
experience of this is,
but I do know that
sometimes in the past,
there have been Asian projects
that come out that maybe don't
make you laugh or aren't good.
And then you feel like
you have to support it.
And I was never good at that.
I don't really like to
do that, unfortunately.
So that's what was
fun about "Asian AF,"
and I think that's always the
goal is that nobody gets pass.
Do you know what I mean?
Like, I'm not going to just--
we're not going to like it just
because it's Asian and say, oh,
isn't this great and pat
each other on the back.
I mean, it still
has to be funny.
It has to be genuinely funny.
Otherwise, I wouldn't
be a part of it.
And I think that's
what I appreciate
about the other people.
And the UCB too,
I mean, the reason
why it's got a home at the UCB
is that the standards of UCB
are very high.
And that's why, you
know, part of why
we're in there and learning
and getting better.
And these are people who
get to perform there.
So that was just important
to me as far as someone
coming to a project like this.
And I think also it's
funny because sometimes
that's the first thing
people think when they hear,
oh, it's an Asian show.
Oh, it's probably just eh.
You know?
Like, you almost,
yeah, that's right.
That's what I used to think.
That's why I used to
think, oh, they're
probably just giving a pass to
a bunch of sketches that are
just like, you know, only OK.
And so that's why--
I forget that because now
it's been going for so long
that I go, no, that's great.
I love the show.
What as the question?
[LAUGHTER]
JEREMY: All right, so
I'm going to open it up
to the floor for any
questions you might have.
But I do have one more
question before I throw it out
to your all.
So in the show
particularly, what
are some of your favorite
jokes or sketches
that have come out of it?
KAY KAANAPU: "Ghost
in the Shell--
The Musical" where they--
Will, you wrote it with Mike?
WILL CHOI: Yeah, I wrote it
with Mike Lane and Tess Paras.
KAY KAANAPU: Yeah, it's
pretty much "Wizard of Oz,"
but yeah, with
"Ghost in the Shell"
and all these people,
Tilda and Matt and--
KEIKO AGENA: They all
make an appearance.
KAY KAANAPU: They all
KEIKO AGENA: It's so nice
of them to come down.
WILL CHOI: Yeah,
it was very nice.
It was right when
the movie came out.
And Mike, Tess, and I, we
had not watched the movie
or knew anything
about the anime.
So we just wrote a
musical based off what
we thought the movie was about.
And so it was about
like these characters.
KEIKO AGENA: So close, too.
[INAUDIBLE]
WILL CHOI: It was really
accurately, actually.
And it's these four
characters, and they're looking
for the ghost in the shell.
And they have to take the
yellow face road to get there.
And it was-- it went
over really well.
But, yeah, it's--
I can't say if there was any
specific moment or joke--
KAY KAANAPU: I have one.
WILL CHOI: --that--
KEIKO AGENA: Go [? Kay. ?]
KIM COOPER: One of
the funniest things
I feel like I have seen at
UCB was [? Gibonnie. ?] Shout
out to [? Gibonnie. ?] She did--
she did a character that was
one of the-- what, was a plate?
WILL CHOI: She was a plate.
KIM COOPER: She was a plate
from "Beauty and the Beast"
from the "Be Our
Guest," you know,
when all the plates are dancing.
This is a plate.
This is a plate also.
So like, who's to say?
Who's to say what
race this plate is?
But she-- it was so funny.
It didn't have nothing
to do with race at all.
But it was this plate that like
was like lamenting how strict
and how hard it was to be
a plate living in "Beauty
and the Beast" and like all the
training they had to go through
to learn this dance,
[? like, you need therapy. ?]
KEIKO AGENA: --fucking nut job.
KIM COOPER: Yeah, and it
was so-- like I had tears.
It was so funny.
And it was also like,
yeah, it had nothing at all
to do with race
and [? Gibonnie ?]
is just a very smart,
[INAUDIBLE] woman.
KEIKO AGENA: She's also
a special performer.
She's so good.
KIM COOPER: Yeah,
she's very, very good.
It was amazing.
Shout out to you,
[? Gibonnie. ?]
WILL CHOI: Yeah, I
mean, like for me,
there's so many great moments
that we've had in the show,
and the improv is
great and sketches
and stand-up and stuff.
But for me when I look at
the totality of the show,
the thing that I like
the most is the diversity
amongst the Asian community
that's in both the audience
and on stage.
Because you see these performers
do improv together or sketch
together, and it's like East
Asian, and Southeast Asian,
South Asian, mixed
race, you know,
our show features
majority women, you know.
And it's like such a cool
experience to see that on stage
and see how much
diversity there is
within the
Asian-American community.
And so yeah, it's so
hard for me to say
which specific moment there is.
But when I just look
up on that stage
and I see how different
everyone looks,
yet, we're all under
the same umbrella.
It makes me very
happy to see that.
ZAC OYAMA: How many times
have you guys heard the word
totality in the last two days?
WILL CHOI: Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
ZAC OYAMA: Yeah,
similarly, like it's
hard to describe improv scenes
without sounding insane.
KEIKO AGENA: I know.
[? The ?] [? worst. ?]
ZAC OYAMA: I mean, you have
very funny improv shows,
to me, if I were to--
it'd be like, I was a cat,
and then there were eagles.
It doesn't translate
in this conversation.
But they're very fun.
And what you're saying
about like the difference
of like Asian
experiences, I feel
like that's been like
such a fun challenge
and thing to figure
out with these shows
is like, we're all coming
from such different places.
And there's maybe not as
much shared language there,
so to speak, that lends itself
to being on the same page,
copy wise.
But like, that is something
that we're actively
learning from and figuring out.
It's been fun.
JEREMY: Awesome.
Thank you.
ZAC OYAMA: What were
we talking about?
KIM COOPER: What
was the question?
JEREMY: All right, let's go
to open it up to the floor.
Anybody have any
questions. [? Liliana? ?]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, do I
need a mic, I mean?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KIM COOPER: Gmail, are you here?
KEIKO AGENA: Gmail?
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
Thank you so much
for being here.
So with so much great talent
and all of the great writers,
how does it work?
Do you have like a
testing lab or like
do you just present in front
of each other all the jokes
and then figure out which one
is actually going into the show?
How do you see all
the goodness that's
going into each of the shows?
KIM COOPER: A testing
lab would be cool.
We should get that.
WILL CHOI: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
KEIKO AGENA: Can we be here?
WILL CHOI: Yeah, can we figure
out how to do that here?
No, you know,
actually, the process
is people, when it
comes to sketches,
they'll write
their own sketches.
Or they have done sketches
in previous shows,
and they'll submit it to us.
Keiko and I, we are the
ones that are producing,
so we'll read them, and we'll
kind of like see if, you know,
it hits a certain
standard that we like.
And so that's how
the sketches work.
With the improv, we
have one improv team
called [? Goldtron ?] which
Zac and Kim are both on.
And they're all
Asian-American UCB performers.
And that improv is
made up on the fly.
So there's no rehearsing there.
KIM COOPER: There's no way
to know what we'll say.
WILL CHOI: Yeah, you never
know what's going to happen,
but they--
"Asian AF" is their
monthly slot to perform.
And then with
stand-ups, it's usually,
you know, it's people submitting
it like this one kid I saw,
he's a half-Chinese,
half-black comedian.
And he's still in college.
And I saw him do a
three-minute open mic.
And I was like, I have to
get this guy on the show.
He was solid.
And he killed it.
KIM COOPER: Wasn't he here
on his like summer break?
KEIKO AGENA: Yes.
WILL CHOI: He was here for
summer break for college.
KEIKO AGENA: Yes, he's too
young and too good, man.
WILL CHOI: But, yeah,
there's different
kind of ways to kind of--
some people will submit
and they'll show me
their stand-up set
and so I'll be like,
great, I want this person
or [? recommendations. ?]
And then there's just
other various ways of people
to like get on to the show,
whether it's we just ask them
to do a favor and be like,
hey, you're a dancer, can you do
this dancing thing or whatever?
So it's a little
hodge-podgy in terms
of getting a show
together, but usually it
comes together very nicely once
the night of the show happens.
KEIKO AGENA: And I was going to
add one thing really quickly.
Will is really good
about reaching out
to people in the
Asian-American community that
are in the entertainment world,
even if he doesn't know them.
And so we've gotten,
like, Margaret Cho's
been on the show
and [INAUDIBLE]..
I mean, that part has
been part of it too.
WILL CHOI: Yeah,
yeah, just the people
who have been interested
in being on this show
has kind raised the
level of "Asian AF,"
like so Margaret Cho, Sheng
Wang, Aparna Nancherla,
Joel Kim Booster.
And just so many great
actors have been a part of it
and want to be in
the show as well.
And we just haven't
had the scheduling
yet for them to come on.
KEIKO AGENA: Yeah,
there are a lot
of people that are in the
"as soon as time permits,"
they'll get on the show.
WILL CHOI: And it's
really exciting
because we have great guests
lined up in future months
that I can't announce just yet.
But we can also announce
that Ronny Chieng, who
is from "The Daily
Show" is going
to be doing stand-up at Asian
AF New York next month, which
is very exciting.
But yeah, it's a
really cool thing
to see how excited everyone
is, not just audience members,
but also performers and
kind of well-known people
who want to be a part of
this thing that we're doing.
And we're seeing it in LA,
both in LA and New York.
Dan Lee and Alex
Song are the hosts
in New York,
producers in New York.
And they're doing a great
job at kind of building
that community out there too.
I feel like I talked a lot.
KEIKO AGENA: No, that's
good. [? That was a good-- ?]
[? that was the question. ?]
JEREMY: Any-- oh,
any other questions?
ZAC OYAMA: Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: So when you're
coming up with humor,
how do you decide sort
of what is allowed?
Because whenever you
make a joke, you know,
there's obviously
a tension making
people feel a little
bit uncomfortable,
but then at the
same time, you don't
want to cross the
line wherever that is.
So like as an Asian
person, sometimes I'll
tell a joke in front
of my white friends.
And then I'll say,
wait, but I don't
want you to think that
you're allowed to say that.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
So, you know, if you don't
know them especially.
So how do you balance that?
KEIKO AGENA: She's ready.
She's ready.
Kim is ready.
KIM COOPER: Oh no, I just--
I want to share from
my own experience,
because I have run into
that a lot in my life too.
And like I mentioned
before, a lot
of how I ended up coming to
comedy when I was younger
was making jokes
about being Asian
and at the expense of my being
Asian which, as an adult,
I'm like, hey man, wish
you hadn't done that.
But I think it is hard
sometimes for people
to know that it's like, oh
yeah, you can't do that too.
But for us-- and I'll only
speak for myself here--
in our adult lives, I
was at a show recently.
We have the unique
experience that most
of the time, our audience
is a lot of Asian people,
a lot of Asian-American people.
And so that gives
us, I think, a luxury
that we don't have all
the time to do stuff
that feels like it
would maybe not hit
if it was a different crowd.
We did a show recently,
all Asian people.
And the suggestion
was banana, which
like, at least in
my experience, is
something people call an
East Asian person when
they are yellow on the outside
and white on the inside.
And when we got the
suggestion, I was like banana!
And then I was like,
if I do this right now,
it might alienate the
audience who is mostly white.
And I was like, I don't want
them to feel like they messed
up or that they said--
because they didn't--
I'm sure that person,
whoever suggested that,
didn't mean it as
like, you're a banana.
KEIKO AGENA: They were
just thinking of a banana.
KIM COOPER: They were
just like, I love bananas.
It's my favorite fruit, snack.
It's healthy for
you, love potassium.
And it was like one
of those situations
where I was like,
not exactly, oh,
making sure that they can't say
that as well, but like making
sure that like I
didn't want to like
alienate people in that moment.
So I was like, I want you guys
to still like laugh and have
a good time at this improv
show, not feel like you're
being chastised for that.
That was like a really
interesting thing.
ZAC OYAMA: I feel
like, yeah, like
as far as like making a joke
about myself, I can do that.
Like, I usually don't,
but if something comes up
where it's like--
you know, people want to get
food or something and I'm like,
I want to get ramen or whatever
and there's a joke there,
maybe I'll make it.
But if I'm in a
situation where it's
like we're trying to parse
out if like a white person can
make the joke at me, the
answer is almost always no.
And so like, it's
not really on you.
They should know that.
It should be obvious.
And I think people can do a
better job of calling people
out on that.
I don't know.
[? AUDIENCE: ?] Yeah.
ZAC OYAMA: Yeah.
So just be really
mean to your friends.
[? AUDIENCE: ?] Don't be
mean, they're friends.
WILL CHOI: Best advice,
best advice of the day.
KEIKO AGENA: Is that
how we're wrapping?
KIM COOPER: Alienate
your friends.
AUDIENCE: So my question
is around content
created by people of color.
What are some of your
recommendations for podcasts,
movies, film, comedy
that you particularly
like that are created
by people of color?
KEIKO AGENA: Oh,
that's good one.
ZAC OYAMA: [? I'll ?]
[? think about this. ?]
WILL CHOI: Collegehumor.com.
[LAUGHTER]
KIM COOPER: The guy
who called Zac Oyama.
He loves ramen.
Needs help with his Gmail?
ZAC OYAMA: I mean,
this is just--
no one is-- this is a
kind of an obvious one.
I used work on the
show "Key & Peele."
And I felt like the
ways in which they
were able to comment on
race and not comment on it,
and like the amount of
material they were able to mine
from specific, you know,
racially-charged scenarios
I found very inspiring
for sketch comedy
and have since been trying
to apply it when I can.
WILL CHOI: In terms
of podcasts, there's
a podcast collective called
the "Potluck Podcast," which
is maybe like eight or 10
Asian-American hosted podcasts
that, you know, cover a
range of different topics.
Keiko and I have a podcast
that is a part of that.
And, yeah, if you
check that out, there's
just a lot of different
podcasts that you could
see that have Asian-American
hosts, which, I think,
in the podcast world, it's
pretty white-dominated,
at least the popular ones are.
So it's just one resource.
I'm sure there are also others,
but that's just one resource
that people can
look up podcasts.
"Potluck Podcast,"
that's what it's called.
KEIKO AGENA: This is not
controversial or helpful
at all, but this is honest.
"So You Think You Can Dance--"
[? AUDIENCE: ?] Woo.
KEIKO AGENA: --is like-- what?
It's like one of
my favorite shows.
I watch it all the time.
There's so many friggin'
Asian people show right now.
There's Lex Ishimoto.
There's Dassy.
There's Koi-nay.
There's Marko.
It's like half Asian, I think.
And then there's other
diversity on there too.
Damn, I love dance.
Oh, you already had it too.
KIM COOPER: I would say
my favorite ones are
very obvious and not
controversial at all also.
I think Aziz Ansari is a genius.
I think that Mindy
Kaling is a genius.
I think that Ali
Wong is a genius.
And I think it's really
important when people-- like,
I'm so annoying.
Whenever my friends bring
up one of those people,
I'm like, yeah,
and they're Asian.
Like, note it's not like
about them being Asian.
But note that you--
this is like me talking to
like a white person-- like,
note that you as a white
person still like their comedy.
And sometimes it is--
this is the same thing
that I said before.
Sometimes-- I think Aziz does
a really good job of this,
like, you know, talks
about like being Muslim
and his experiences with
his parents finding out
that he eats bacon and eats
pork and stuff like that,
but then also being like,
hey, I like this girl.
She doesn't like me back,
or she has a boyfriend.
That's hard.
And using those as like
opportunities to like learn.
And yeah whenever people
are like Ali Wong's
stand-up special is so
funny, I'm like, yeah,
it's great how she could
talk about, you know,
her experiences
as an Asian woman
and also talk about
her experiences
as a woman and mainstreaming
things like her pregnancy
and miscarriage and like other
things like that and then
also just be like one of
the stand-ups of all time.
Oh, you don't want to?
OK.
[INAUDIBLE]
KAY KAANAPU: You
guys took all mine.
But I did actually just see
Hasan Minhaj's Netflix comedy
special and man, that was good.
Like, not just like
comedically, but the drama
that he had talking about like
his family and his experience
and then being able
to flip like getting
laughs off of like moments where
he was almost close to tears.
I also have to
say "Key & Peele."
Like, I loved "Key & Peele."
Stuff like that makes
me feel like gooey
and warm inside because
it just feels so funny
and like cathartic.
I once saw Keegan Michael
Key in an improv show
at [? IOS ?] like years ago.
And the range of
characters that he did just
like in one 15-minute
set, it was just amazing.
So yeah, so Keegan Michael Key
and Hasan Minhaj is what I got.
KIM COOPER: Can I say one more?
KEIKO AGENA: "Insecure"
is great too.
KIM COOPER: Yeah and also--
truly, this is not
a plug for the show,
but it is a plug for the show.
Like, a lot of the people
that have been on the show
and come through the
show, especially people
who are not as well known
or who are like newer
in their careers, it's
really cool and inspiring
to see them and like--
ZAC OYAMA: At "Asian AF"?
KIM COOPER: Yeah, at "Asian
AF at the Upright Citizens'
Brigade Theatre on
Sunset Boulevard.
But it's just really cool.
And you'd see so much talent.
And you're like, hey, why
aren't you on a TV show?
Hey, why don't you have an
hour special on Comedy Central
or wherever they have
stand-up shows, on Netflix.
KEIKO AGENA: I have two more.
This is a like--
"Superstore" does a great job.
I like all the characters
on "Superstore"
as far as the comedy.
I'll give a shout-out
to "13 Reasons Why,"
which I got to be a part of.
It's kind of a dark show.
But the way that
that show was cast,
it was based upon
the book, and it
wasn't written necessarily
ethnically diverse,
but the way that cast it was.
And it's doing really well.
KAY KAANAPU: Oh wait.
And-- "Black-ish," "Black-ish"
and "Fresh Off The Boat,"
awesome shows, especially
because it's like that,
you know, classic
family experience.
So like, what, you
don't like these shows?
What, you don't like families?
[LAUGHTER]
KIM COOPER: You hate families?
KEIKO AGENA: [? We're ?]
against families, man.
KAY KAANAPU: There's families
everywhere, so, yeah.
WILL CHOI: Yeah, one
show that I really
loved this past season was
"The Good Place" on NBC,
a very diverse cast.
And Manny Jacinto who
is Filipino-Chinese
is one of the main characters
of that show and actually
the "Asian AF" last
month, I think?
KEIKO AGENA: Yeah.
WILL CHOI: Last month
or two months ago.
And yeah, I mean, it's--
you know, lots of good
content out there now
that are trying to, you know,
work harder at being more
inclusive and more diverse.
And just like,
lastly, "Asian AF,"
you see all these
great, great people who
are on stage and who
are, like I said,
South Asian, Southeast Asian.
We've had East
Asian and mixed race
and, you know, all come from
a very different experience.
And that's a great place to kind
of feel a sense of community,
immediate community.
JEREMY: Yeah, one last
question, [? Phil. ?]
KEIKO AGENA: Four
minutes, three minutes.
AUDIENCE: [? Sorry ?] [? for ?]
[? jumping in. ?] So I was
wondering, like, what are some
ways beyond coming to the show
that we can support people who
are in the [INAUDIBLE]---- oh,
for sure.
[LAUGHTER]
KEIKO AGENA: Do you
like our PayPal?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
KIM COOPER: [INAUDIBLE]
Zac's email.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, well, I work
on YouTube so, unfortunately,
[INAUDIBLE].
For people like us who are
at home with two small kids,
it's hard for us to get out.
I mean, you can follow
people's Facebooks, Instagrams.
I've heard casting
directors will
look at people's
Instagrams to see
how many followers
[? in the community ?]
subscribe.
Are there kinds of things
that we could possibly do?
KEIKO AGENA: Sign
those kids up too.
Have them follow us.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
ZAC OYAMA: I think you
hit on a lot of it,
like, the idea of
supporting people online.
If you can't make it out
to a show, like, obviously,
support people's Twitter
and Instagram and stuff.
It feels funny to be
like, hey, follow me.
But, yeah.
Add Zac Oyama.
[LAUGHTER]
And yeah, for "Asian AF" in
particular, I know Will--
I know they spend a lot of
money to try to make sure
that the show is recorded
in a way that looks good
and take pictures
that look good.
And that costs money.
And is it a Kickstarter or
some kind of thing that like--
there's ways to support
financially if you want.
And like, you know,
even just like if you
see something you like that
has Asian talent in it,
you can share that.
You know, if you know,
you're not the type of person
to share things
online, like, you know,
maybe support that in that way.
WILL CHOI: Yeah, in terms of
like the show specifically,
we haven't put any of our
content online just yet,
hopefully soon.
But we do have a PayPal
that is accepting donations
if you go to
asianafshow.com, you
can always let us rent
this space for free.
[LAUGHTER]
You guys have so much room here.
But--
KIM COOPER: [? We need room ?]
for an idea lab.
KEIKO AGENA: Yeah,
where's our idea lab?
We need to workshop some stuff.
ZAC OYAMA: We're just
trying to figure out.
Like, it would be helpful
if we could all surf today.
KEIKO AGENA: Yeah.
WILL CHOI: Guys, you
have the resources.
Let us use it.
KEIKO AGENA: You
have everything.
WILL CHOI: No, but,
yeah, there is--
you know, yeah, donations are
a great way for us to kind
keep the show alive.
And the donations that we've
gotten also pay for New York
too.
And shout out to Google New
York for letting us kind of--
we were just in
New York last week,
and they showed us
around, and they're
very supportive of the show.
And they came out to the "Asian
AF" New York show and stuff,
so.
But yeah, you know, hopefully
we'll get more content out
in the internet, but--
KIM COOPER: I would say also,
like, this is a little bit more
involved, but like if
you do see-- like on TV,
you're watching TV and like
a co-star or a guest star
is an Asian person, person of
color that you think is funny,
look them up.
Look them up on IMDb,
then by their YouTube.com,
their social media.
Find them on there.
But like a lot of people
create their own content.
So although you might
see them from a TV show,
you might see them
on YouTube, you
might see them listed even
just on a lineup for "Asian
AF" or something like
that, so often they
have their own content.
And I think it's important
to support that, share that,
truly the internet, Google.com.
It's good.
WILL CHOI: Yeah.
Yeah.
Is there anyone?
KAY KAANAPU: I
think also-- and you
said you're a father, right?
So just, you know, allowing
like maybe your kids
just to like, you know,
support them and be-- let them
be creative in their own voice.
Maybe even reach out to
your local Asian community.
I know we've done the Comedy
Comedy Festival that Will also
helps produce, and that's
an all-Asian comedy festival
they've had a couple of years.
That was at the
Japanese-American Cultural
Center.
Like, reach out to
those communities
and be involved with them,
and give the young people
the freedom to express their
voice as an Asian, as a person,
as a person of color.
You know just allowing them
to be like, you fit in,
you belong here, you may not
see yourself up there yet,
but you are here, so you do
exist and help them be seen.
KEIKO AGENA: So can
we get a commitment
from you that you
will [INAUDIBLE]??
KAY KAANAPU: This
like our [INAUDIBLE]..
KEIKO AGENA: [INAUDIBLE] Oh OK.
KIM COOPER: We've got two more.
KEIKO AGENA: Two more.
WILL CHOI: Two more, well--
KEIKO AGENA: "Asian AF," 2032.
WILL CHOI: But the most serious
thing that really, though, is
we want to use this space.
So someone here--
someone here must
have some power to do this.
Let's talk after this.
KIM COOPER: Throw
any [INAUDIBLE]..
WILL CHOI: Because
then we'll practice,
and we'll do our shows here.
And then you guys can
just watch it for free.
KEIKO AGENA: Yeah.
And we know at Google, you
want everything to come to you.
WILL CHOI: Yeah.
KEIKO AGENA: So we'll
bring the show here.
WILL CHOI: But first,
we need to figure out
Zac's Gmail situation.
ZAC OYAMA: I'm all lost.
KIM COOPER: Gmail.com.
WILL CHOI: Yeah.
JEREMY: All right,
well, thank you
so much, Kay, Kim,
Keiko, Will, Zac,
thank you so much for coming
to speak with us today.
Let's go ahead and give
them a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]